my hope is that in listening to either
book people find it reassuring that so
many of the people they might put on a
pedestal have all the same problems that
they do
it's not that they succeed because they
lack insecurities or lack problems or
lack self-defeating habits it's that
they've figured out how to manage those
things these world-class performers
don't have superpowers the rules they've
crafted for themselves allow the bending
of reality to such an extent that it
might seem that way but they've learned
how to do this and so can you these
so-called rules are often uncommon
habits and bigger questions so if you
want to change your life significantly
you want to change your business or
career significantly you want to change
how you relate to other people
significantly the magic is really in the
questions these two books can give you
not just a set toolkit of better
questions but the increased ability to
craft questions of your own they get you
the results you want and that is as
close to a superpower as I think it's
possible in a surprising number of cases
the power is in the absurd the more
absurd the more impossible the question
the more profound the answers
take for instance a question that serial
billionaire Peter Thiel likes to ask
himself and others if you have a ten
year plan of how to get somewhere you
should ask why can't you do this in six
months for purposes of illustration here
I might reword that to what might you do
to accomplish your ten-year goals in the
next six months if you had a gun against
your head I do recommend that everybody
pursue if they can the bare bones of
drawing let's say the bare bones of
music just so they develop greater
sensitivity in
seeing and hearing and listening because
that transfers to everything
animal 1 is 20 minutes of seated
meditation in the morning
remember 2 would be journaling in some
short form isolating the things that are
most important to get done that day the
big dominoes to tip over or if you're
feeling really stressed out morning
pages from Julia Cameron very very
helpful then if I had to pick a third I
would say a short bout of exercise if I
checked those 3 boxes every day feels
more in control
[Music]